Hello and welcome back. Hello, Kieran. How are
you? I'm good. Thank you, David. How are
you? Yes.
I'm very well. Thank you. I am looking
forward to part two of the Docker Kubernetes
and Laravel edition.
It's gonna be a tough one today.
I feel like you have to be really
high energy after your intro video.
I have considered so many times making a
joke about the polarity between the higher energy
intro and then my completely
low energy personality.
I think we shared that. So, yeah, we've
we've got lots of different things we could
do today, haven't we?
Oh, we do. So let's
let's build a little bit of context here.
So this session is we are trying to
show how to take a Laravel application
from your local machine, produce a container based
development environment using Docker and Docker Compose, and
show you the real kind of day one
deployed to Kubernetes scenario.
What we tried to do in the last
session was squeeze all Adam to two well,
two sessions now. That's actually I guess this
part three, we did non Laravel, then we
did Laravel, and now we're back to continue
with Laravel.
Mhmm. And I think the problem with that
is we tried to do all of and
all Laravel stuff in a single session. And
I think what we've realized is we really
just need to kinda slow down into this
bit by bit. Like,
there's a lot of different things that we
need to get right to really produce a
developer experience that's gonna work for people and
not be too cumbersome.
Yeah. Although,
you know, not to put people off, but
we've not spent that many hours on it.
It's that we've done across three sessions. But
if if we were at work and not
talking through things, that that and I if
this was lunchtime
and I spent three hours doing what we've
done so far, I'd feel like it was
a good day's work so far. Oh, yeah.
Definitely. Yeah. Yeah. That that's that's true.
And I think now that we're getting into
the individual components of the Laravel application,
you know, we we try to kind of
build a full pipeline on the last one,
and now we can go back and clean
up a few of those artifacts that maybe
aren't as great as we wanted.
So, John, we've got what we've got to.
We've
got a dev environment.
We're
building the front end assets.
We're populating the database.
It's
we deployed it to your local Kubernetes.
Right?
We did deploy it to Kubernetes.
Yep.
We left a few things to the imagination,
though. So I think if I just let's
pop up my my code.
My work code. This is pair programmed.
So
we put together a Docker proposed file.
We have an engineized container that is delivering
our front end assets. We have a PHP
container that is delivering the Laravel code.
And we have MariaDB,
which has a basic health check that allows
us to really provide a local experience for
working in containers that should be one command
using those health checks to handle the orchestration
component.
We have a Dockerfile
with multiple layers.
We did our best to put together a
base layer with dev tooling that we would
require and production tooling. So we've a PD
with mySQL extension.
We then augment that with a few developer
tools. Right now, we are bundling in Node.
Js and NPM to do asset compilation,
but one of the major themes for today.
We this is not something that we would
expect or this is not something we think
is is an ideal
what
else do we have? We have then
the FPM
image, which we're using to actually ship to
production.
We have a test layer, which we're gonna
run our test against.
And we have some asset compilation to produce
an asset production image, which can be deployed
separately,
which we did
show with
this really
primitive deployment YAML for Kubernetes, which deployed our
FPM and Nginx containers site by site.
Mhmm.
We added in because it was late in
the last session. Oh, this is how we
would draw on our database migrations, but we
didn't actually run that ourselves.
That's something that we will need to tackle
at some point. But we are gonna use
a concept code and a container. And if
I remember correctly on the last conversation,
I said there were really two ways to
handle this. The other way would be that
you could spin off a job
that ran alongside of your deployment to handle
the migrations asynchronously,
which is a flow you may wish to
adopt as
your migrations are additive.
They work in a way that no, like,
no new queries
yeah.
No new key queries could potentially break with
an older version of the schema. Yeah.
I think that's right.
Yeah. That's a lot. To do to do
it as part of an init container,
the migrations have to be
safe to run more than once. Right?
To do it as part of an an
Internet container.
Yes. So your your migrations definitely have to
be idempotent. They're gonna run every single
pod
that deploys.
But more importantly,
I guess, is that they have to be
able to handle some sort of locking mechanism
because there is the there
is the chance or likelihood that two pods
will try to run at roughly the same
time during that deployment.
Now we did briefly talk about update strategies
and how we can use that to limit
that risk. But really, you just wanna be
able to make sure that your migration says,
hey. I'm gonna lock this table right now.
No one else gets access.
It will put up that latency on other
pods starting up, but it definitely is the
safest way to handle our migration in this
kind of situation.
A lot of migration libraries,
there's obviously different ways to do it. They'll
have one table which shows
what version of the migration you're on, and
that's the only one you need to lock.
Right? So you wouldn't be
you wouldn't be
contending necessarily with live transactions happening on the
database for normal traffic. Yeah. Exactly. Spot on.
Like, it's I think
I think every migration library I played with
in the past has had a migrations table
which gets locked on a migration run to
protect it, which means your application will still
handle traffic pretty well. Alright.
So we know our Docker file.
Why were we installing NPM? Is that just
left over? Because it looks like we're using
an NPM
image to build the assets.
Oh, it was on dev, wasn't it, that
we were installing NPM?
Yeah. We do augment our development. So we
can figure out a way that we could
run this through a d shell environment so
that we could have, like, an interactive terminal.
I still think that's a really good way
of doing it, but what we didn't cover
was automatic re compilation
of those assets and then the ability to
deliver them for a different container. So it
may be that we break up
that environment and
well, we could talk about that in a
minute. I I think we we will separate
that.
And the d shell will only be for
the PHP commands because those are the ones
that I think are gonna run interactively,
and we'll try and move the MPM stuff
to be a more automated fashion.
Which is a diff the which which is
the difference that comes from the JavaScript stuff
being sort of built,
compiled
language,
whereas PHP is interactive. So there's a big
difference, isn't there? There's an explicit step of,
now it's ready to execute
in JavaScript.
Yes. Exactly.
You know, those those assets are assets are
being delivered.
There's no like, it's not like we have
to go ahead and run composer install. I
mean, we do have an NPM install, but
we'll handle that separately. It's not like we
need to do composer
cache for you. It's not like we have
to do database migrations. I mean, the only
interactive component here is Laravel. Our Laravel application
is what we're developing. The assets were something
that enriched that application with other things, and
we can push that to the site and
and have that work in a slightly different
way.
Yeah.
Yep. Okay.
So what we're gonna do we I think
we're gonna focus on the the asset stuff
today. That's where most of the questions came
via YouTube comments or Reddit or Twitter.
What I will suggest is for anyone that
is watching, if you want to ask questions,
you can leave them on the YouTube chat
live, and we will do our best to
ask them. If you have questions that you
wish to ask after this video or you're
not watching live, there's a link on the
bottom of the screen.
And if you're feeling brave and want to
come and join on and ask a question,
then we we're gonna try and encourage that
too. So you can take a message and
just follow YouTube. Either way to go.
Peter has a very loud plane overhead.
I think it's a helicopter. I'll just
I'll just mute Keith. We don't need to
hear from him anyway. So
sorry, mate. Alright.
So Kieran has told me that my link
is missing in HTTP.
It's not. I thought it was cool. I
thought that was Oh, right. That's on purpose.
Yeah.
I mean, everything that like, I wanted people
to know it was a URL, so I
put, like, colon slash slash. I didn't think
that HTTP or HTTPS was really
you're making me do all my things there.
Anyway,
I
thought it was cool. That's it. That's it.
Alright.
You want to
you want to protocol less URL, you don't
put the code long on.
Slash slash?
Yeah. If you you do a hyperlink like
that,
and it'll stick to the
which is very useful if you're serving your
site under HTTP and HTTPS,
for instance.
Okay.
Anyway
So today, I've learned something.
Alright. So let's take a look at our
current
development environment for this application then. So
what we said well, I don't know. We
did we use Maker just? Because I always
change Maker. Okay.
So what we said was we wanted this
d shell
environment to provide something that felt like I
was developing locally, but with the parity of
that container based deployment.
Mhmm. And that means I'm inside the container
right now.
What do we want to do?
In fact, let's just split this first. So
I could do a DCPS to see what
I have running when I do the make
d shell command.
So we do have a MariaDB database self.
Good.
We have an NGINX service static assets
and, hopefully, proxy in any request for PHP
back through to the FPM container.
We have our FPM server running,
and we have an interactive
shell.
Yep. Which is the same image, right, as
the
Exact same image with the same volume notes.
Yep. Just working as is.
So what we need now is confirmation
that this application is working. So
and I'm now typing h t t p
s. Sorry. Local host eighty eighty.
Hey.
Alright.
Okay. Not too bad. We haven't actually logged
in, have we? We're just trusting it works.
The database is there.
Looks like the assets are compiling correctly.
Yep.
So hello there. Welcome to Ping CRM.
We can artificially create five hundreds and four
hundreds. We have the ability to bridge organizations.
But this is not the fastest application right
now, and that is because I'm developing on
a Mac.
Now there is a flag to speed that
up.
So maybe that should just be the first
quality of life thing that we're gonna do.
And there's a whole new mechanism in Docker
for Mac that does some sort of syncing,
but I've not tried it out.
Say what?
There's a new file system.
Something RPC.
You got some link goodness there for me
to check out? Guess I can just Google
it over for Mac. Yep. If you're on
the RPC.
Think RPC. Yeah.
Not that.
It's in the new edge thing. So what
it does is instead of
it it
in the container uses a few the user
land fuse file system
that
has some RPC
thing. So it's syncing the Mac file system
events. It's then pushing them
to Docker.
It's not actually that much faster, allegedly.
So people I know have used it said
it's about 10 or 20% faster.
Okay. I am gonna enable the delegated feature
that I am somewhat familiar with. Yeah.
Let's see if we
see if we get a little bit of
improvement.
Do I spent
sorry?
Do a quick benchmark first before we change
it.
Let me just get the documentation so we
can share that to the Docker for Mac
delegated folder.
There we go. Okay. So And people get
very confused between delegated and cached.
Yeah. We'll try and cover that too then.
So how do we benchmark this? What we
wanna do is time how long it takes
for a curl request, I guess,
to pull down that index page. So let's
see. Localhost,
it it it it time.
22.4Seconds.
Although, that didn't give us a login page,
so let's render that too.
Alright. It looks like we're run
two point eight seconds. It definitely felt longer
than that here.
Is it not?
Maybe there's some sort of cold start booking.
I wonder if Laravel
in Devon caches
things. Do you know what I mean?
Maybe that was just under three seconds. Right?
Okay. So let's see if I can get
a little bit of performance out of that
then. So if we find delegated
there we go.
These are the three options that we have.
These are,
I believe, max specific things that change the
way the fail synchronization
well, they don't change the way it works.
They change the expectations on requesting fails from
the container side.
Mhmm.
So by default, I believe we get consistent.
That means whenever I modify a fail on
the host
and I then make a request against that
container, it is going away
and until both of those fail systems are
in complete sync before responding to any of
the requests coming in. This means that if
I modify
what did we get on this page? See,
I want to change dashboard.
Wait. That's not as easy as I'm hoping
it is.
Let's assume this is the template.
Go away. Okay.
Have I saved this from my oh, I
had log in,
and I'm not logged in here. Going well.
Okay. So
oh, it didn't.
Oh, Windows, the default behavior has not changed,
or have I just changed the wrong template?
Anyway, let's talk about it first.
Then we've got cached.
Cached just means that we are gonna
trust the host container as always correct.
Yep. And what that means is that we'll
happily take a little bit of
delay in a response.
Delegated means just invert that. It means whoever's
in the container, just use it. Now from
a performance point of view, just always using
delegated means that when you're working with your
application, you're always gonna get fast responses.
It may mean that you have to refresh
the page
to see that new change come in just
after. So it depends on how quickly your
workflow is between changing something on a template
site
and then moving over to your browser and
refreshing that. So I feel from a experience
point of view that fully delegated is better
because I would prefer that the
page responded faster even if it is not
entirely accurate
for the changes I've made. I agree with
that. I think it's
a no brainer for stuff that containers writing.
Right? So if you're mounting a logs folder
or, like, a temp a cache folder out
to your host,
delegated
is what you want because
there might be a slight delay in you
looking at that file on the host, but
you want the
you want the Docker file system to able
to write to that quickly without waiting for
updates.
It's also it's less of it's less obvious,
but I think it's the right behavior for
the code you're mounting because in your typical
workflow, you're gonna hit save, and then you're
gonna take a small amount of time to
switch window. And most of the time, the
sync will have happened before you get there.
It's really unlikely you're gonna be able to
run it in the few microseconds it takes.
And this is a problem for PHP specifically,
right, in other interpreted languages in a way
that it's not for
Go
Because if you're compiling Yeah. You if you've
got loads of source code and you're compiling
it into a binary file and the binary
file is the thing that you're mounting
into the container, that's one file to sync.
Whereas a typical JavaScript
not JavaScript. A typical sort of non minified,
non compiled JavaScript
library or PHP library. There's thousands of files,
lots of dependencies
that all have to be synced before it
works.
Yeah. Exactly. I I want a lot of
like, compared languages don't suffer this because, generally,
the completion steps is just explicit. People are
familiar with it. They have to do it
anyway. And if that completion happens when a
Docker image builds, then the tooling knows to
do that and restart the container.
For interpreted languages, yeah, this is the this
is where the pain points are because we
we're working directly with the source code itself.
And it's the file count, isn't it? It's
not the
size of the files, specifically.
Yeah. And if you've got 10 to 10
to small files, like, you know, vendor directories,
then that becomes a challenge. What a lot
of people do is move that vendor directory
into the container using some sort of container
side volume.
These are all things that we'll try and
cover over the next however many sessions we
we continue with this.
Yeah. I I mean, to be honest, for
me, because I work on a Mac as
well, and it's it's quite a slow Mac,
I often don't for instance, I might only
mount the source folder
or I'll actively be mounting the thing I'm
working on, but it involves a bit more
sort of thinking about which files are on
the host, which files are on the folder.
But you can get even without many tweaks,
you can get quite decent performance just by
not mounting much stuff.
You don't need to mount vendors unless you're
actively
editing your composer config and trying things out.
I have a question for you, David. Is
there a way to say mount this folder
except for these subfolders?
Oh, that's tricky. No. There
isn't No.
I've tried that so many times because it
would be really nice to be able to
say mount dot but not vendor.
Unfortunately, that is a challenge.
And then you'd you ran into this weird
checking and egg problem when you do want
to move your composer vendor folder to be
something that only exists in the container through
volume, the where the local one over sits
on the top of it anyway is is
really frustrating,
actually.
It's not a nice developer experience. It's not
really a way to make it nicer. It's
just
yeah. It's just painful. So if you only
want some folders mounted, you have to list
them out in the Docker Compose
explicitly.
You need to list everything except Blender
as I said. You would. Yeah.
I'm not
familiar with a way of yeah. I I
don't think it's on the on the way
of handling that.
Yeah. Thinking about how Unix mount points work,
there's probably not a nice way to do
that.
So I've made two changes to this view
template.
I'm not seeing it updated here. So this
is not the developer experience I'm hoping for.
And it seems to be
So you're already seeing them on host?
Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, no. This is a view. Ah, this
is asset compilation.
It's a building. Pardon me.
Alright. So we need to fix the build
pipeline in order to get this experience that
we need. It's a good illustration of why
people want it.
Yeah. That makes sense. Mhmm.
Alright.
Let's jump down to our Docker Compose because
what we're seeing now is
that
this needs to change.
Okay.
Now that probably means
Using a target
of our own?
I'm trying to work out whether we still
want to go through engine x and has
that consume
our
volume from our node
container that runs in a continuous loop, compiling
the assets whenever things change. Like, it's really
easy for us to That makes sense.
So let's start naively,
I think. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. I was assuming
we would
be doing this as part of Docker build,
but no. We don't have to at all,
do we? We just need something that's constantly
doing the build into a into a volume.
Right. Yeah. I think so. We wanna be
able to they wanna be able we wanna
allow them to change these files whenever they
want, which means let's just fall back. Like,
whenever I speak to people and they're trying
to adopt containers, I say just try and
use the same tooling. Try and have the
same workflow that you have, but use containers
so that you have that party. And
from my experience of working on the the
node
ecosystem
is I would just run, like, an NPM
watch.
I would watch my assets. We can Yeah.
Do all the completion. And we need to
have that same workflow here.
So
what we'll do is we'll start very naively.
We're we're gonna provide a custom NGINX that
has node available.
No? Oh, you're looking at me funny. Okay.
Then we won't start naively. We'll just go
fill Then we end up with two of
them anyway.
One that's running this watch entry point and
one that's running
h t web server. Right. Right. Right.
Okay. Let's add a let's add node. So
And and we've already we're already using the
node image
in the in the live, so it's sort
of bringing us
Alright. So we're gonna add node. We'll use
the same image we were using on our
Docker file,
which is just node 10. Excellent.
We're gonna add a volume,
and we
want to mount
how is the directory structure here? Are we
doing a dot? We didn't bother working out
which files were important last time.
We we we did we went around that
we went down that route of only mounting
select things, and we couldn't work out which
ones are important or not.
K.
Well, like we said, we're gonna do things
slower this time. A bit more explicit. So
if we take a look at our our
package of JSON.
Yeah. We are using webpack.
It's got a watch. So this is what
we wanna use in development. It is
we're
m p m run development
that is doing this.
This is Laravel Mix, which is a wrapper
around webpack.
Leo told us that last time on the
chat.
But there's no directories here. They may just
be working against the same
assets.
We found out last time that the tailwind
config JS was important.
It was important.
There's there's another one.
The pack package dot JSON, obviously.
Yeah. There's something else, I thought.
I think this resources thing
well, that's what PHP in it too.
I think resources
might be enough plus the package JSON plus
the tailwind
plus We
can find out then.
Okay.
Let's go back here. So we're gonna do
package dot JSON, which we know we definitely
need.
Set a working dir of slash code. I
will call slash nodes to remove any ambiguity
between what we do
with PHP.
We also need the tailwind config dot j
s,
which we can just stick in there.
We need
webpack dot mix.
Do you need that trailing slash on the
node to stop it making a file?
Just a question about math.
Yes.
I'm hoping this is going to work.
Yes. The the slash should mean don't name
the file node, and then the slash should
mean put it in directory. I could also
just do package dot JSON.
Yeah.
You need package lock as well, I think,
depending if they're using that.
I'm gonna ignore that file forever.
I don't think we should commit lock files.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
That's I mean, we have containers. We already
have immutability.
We have repeatability.
We have all of this stuff. It's like
the lock fail.
Like, your deployment without containers makes sense, but
I'm
not going to about this last time when
it made perfect sense when we were talking
about production. Does that still hold for development?
When It doesn't make sense for production. Having
the log file and the container for auditability
is fine, but not committing it yet.
The only reason I think we have to
make the lock fail last time was it
required shrink-wrap,
which looked for the lock fail. Yeah. No.
No. I mean, if I'm a developer and
I'm checking out a project,
the earliest time I'm gonna find out I've
been working with the wrong set of dependencies
will be when it runs through CI.
If the developer has access to that lock
file, they get an earlier
discovery
of what versions they should be using.
I I guess we're getting into this. So
the log file is
it guarantee
that the dependencies that I have in a
log file that I have either run test
against to confirm that it works,
and that's Yeah. Now if I remove that
log file, what I'm saying is I trust
whatever is in my package dot JSON, and
I have semantics there to indicate which major,
minor, or patch version of the package I
want,
which means I can always get security updates
and the and the latest and greatest where
needed for packages that I trust not to
be
breaking backwards compatibility regularly. Obviously, those things do
happen, and we can pin those versions and
the the JSON file, which serves a lock.
I just I don't like committing a lock
file because what I'm saying is whenever I
rebuild this project, I never want to get
security updates unless I manually
do it. And I think that's a really
big problem, especially with the amount of vulnerabilities.
I don't think
people that are ignorant to security
really understand how many CVEs there are.
Crypto miner ends up in MPM projects fairly
regularly.
Yeah. So
I guess what I'm thinking about is that
we talked about
we're in the deployment pipeline. We have this
guarantee, don't we, that the the exact image
that the
CI ran against is the one that's being
deployed. So that's giving you some of that
guarantee.
Whereas here,
maybe the developer isn't
someone who runs the tests locally.
We're rebuilding the image fairly regularly. We haven't
we don't really know
that the you know, we're about to start
recompiling the assets on the fly every time
you change a file. So we don't have
that guarantee that the
the code I'm working on, the versions I'm
using have passed the test.
So I guess
you do have the backup, of course, when
the CI
runs.
But, you know, I'm thinking about for some
developers I know, that's eight days later.
Yeah. So if you don't have a a
really tight integration and short feedback loop with
a CI server that runs
within minutes of pushing code somewhere, then, yeah,
you probably do wanna commit a log file.
If you work at for a bank where
you have to manually approve every patch update,
you probably wanna commit a log file. All
our scenarios, I'd say, embrace the ability to
update and get security updates.
A crypto minor may still end up in
there because of that, But, you know, we
we have other ways to audit that code.
Alright.
Let's
leave it there. We've run four lines of
code. So let's if we'll keep making some
progress here.
Okay. Resources, packages on tailwind, and webpack.
Let's see if we have enough to trigger
and run those MPM scripts. So
I'll use my other terminal here. Docker propose
run, interact
with the IT once it run.
We wanna run node.
Let's run the batch command.
Okay. Okay.
So it it's going to make me do
this.
And that's because the folder doesn't exist. Right?
If it existed,
everything would be happy.
When I set the directory to slash the
working directory to slash nodes, so that directory
does exist. Oh, does it get created?
Yeah. So we comment that's it.
Is
that created
what yeah. I don't know when that's created.
Is that created at run time or is
it created?
When the working directory is set and the
container metadata and the container is spun up,
that directory will exist.
And now I can drop back out, bring
these back in
Mhmm.
Then we have what we want. Okay. Cool.
And that's the directory with all the stuff
that we need.
So
I should
we pull up the package dot JSON again.
What we really wanna be able to run
here is MPM run dev.
We will need to do an MPM install.
Wasn't it watch?
The dev runs a watch.
So MPN dev runs development.
Development then runs
oh, no.
Oh, yeah. Okay. You're right. Development just does
the cool way pack stuff. Watch does the
watch. Good catch. Thank you.
We are what what are we gonna run-in?
Does watch do the install?
Do we we're gonna have to run install
and then watch?
So
yeah. We'll need to handle that. I'm not
sure.
Install, but that's good.
I think we have enough.
Don't wanna get too cocky, but I think
it looks good.
What's it doing there? Up building.
Alright. So let's assume this works. Right?
Of course. Right. We need the output public
directory.
Okay. So because the complete the compiled assets
are not something we need available locally, we're
going to use a named volume.
So what we'll do is node public.
Sorry. An anonymous volume. We don't need a
name. We're just saying make the just expose
this directory as a volume.
Yeah.
Now what may happen here is that it
fails on the same step again
because
the CSS,
JS,
and other directories don't exist. I don't know
if MPM will attempt to create them. The
other challenge we have now
is I don't know
if we need anything from this public. I
think only the PHP file is needed by
the PHP container.
Why
don't we do it
using the files on host?
Why do we mount the host? Why mount
it?
I I so I guess this is more
a subjective thing from my point of view.
Because it's compelled assets, like, I was working
with c, if I was working with any
other compelled language, all those things I don't
necessarily need on my host. There there's something
I built. Help me a lot. I can
run my application, and when I kill the
containers, I want them to disappear.
I don't want them back on my host.
And the other aspect would be just that
if you want this to be ubiquitous across
all operating system, Docker for Mac does a
really good job of mapping
the ownership of the files. On Linux, those
files will be owned by Root, and you
have to then jump to a whole bunch
of other groups
Yeah. To map them back to a non
root user on your local host, which means
if I were locally, I'd be able I'd
try and run RM on that file, and
it would say, hey. You need to sit
with that. And that always really frustrating from
someone because you've learned that daily.
The other aspect of it is
do I have another aspect of it?
And Yeah. I Maybe there's any front end
devs
participating.
They can comment, say, like, how often do
you actually
look at
the compiled assets?
Is it never?
I I'm gonna assume never. And, also, I
don't want people to have I I don't
want it to be too easy for people
to work locally and in a container at
the same time. I I want a workflow
that allows people to ignore Docker altogether if
they really want to work locally or use
a container based workflow.
If you end up in a mishmash of
both because I generate assets in a container
and then try to do something with them
locally,
they're compelling in something that like, the targets
are different, and I just I think that
could be rather complicated.
Yeah. I don't have a big clear picture
of whether that stuff's useful for debug.
Because I think the the converse
thing is
associates in PHP world with things like VAR
folders and compile you know, compiled containers and
things.
People
go looking for that stuff on their host,
and then they're confused because
it's not there. So I go look in
this public folder for the assets and get
have a little mental roadblock because there's an
older version of the compiled assets in there
from when I run it on host, and
I'm trying to set breakpoints.
So I don't I don't know how how
important that would be. Let's do it with
the volume.
Alright. So the first thing we're gonna notice
now is that my node modules is gone.
So we're gonna process that across runs.
That was a
dapt mistake of me. So what we're seeing
now is
node modules, stick in that container side volume,
public stick in that container side volume.
We'll drop out of those, run it again.
We'll have access to those two volumes.
I
honestly thought volumes had to be named.
I think I can take a few characters
out of a lot of my files now.
No. They they only have to be named
if you need to be able to reference
them
through other tools. Now that will be something
that we do with the public directory. We
are gonna expose this to NGINX.
But right now, it does not need to
be there.
And an image an image can
declare a volume as well in the build?
It can pass a hint to the container
run time that when you run this image,
this should be exposed
and consumable through other containers if you wish.
Yep. Yes. Okay.
Sure. There's some very weird semantics there, but
yes.
So what I'm gonna do is just drop
out of this and pop back in.
What we should see is
I'm empty node modules.
I wonder if it's not named, I'm not
gonna get persistence.
You just dropped out of the image, didn't
you? The container. Yeah. To show to show
that it would still be there. Oh, you're
still logged into it?
Let's name it
Public.
Or is it because I'm using Docker Proposal
ah, there we go.
Yes. This is I because I'm using a
weird syntax.
So
I'm not gonna be able to tell it
to consume that same volume each time unless
I name it. Okay. Yeah. That's just because
of the way I'm running this container.
Let's try that.
Oh, I did declare it. K.
So we need a node modules,
and we can just use a Tilde which
says use it to fall configuration.
Now anytime I use the Docker Propose run,
it should always use those named volumes, which
have now been created here.
And there's nothing special about them. Well, that
runs
oh, I won't be able to see it
on a Mac, will there?
No. I'm not gonna so it's just all
it does is create a directory under varlib
docker volumes.
And that's what that's where that fails. Let's
there's nothing magic or sophisticated
about that approach.
And I should be able to drop out
this container,
pop back in, run an LS on node
modules. And we won't have to run that
again, though, for as long as that that
named volume makes us do.
If I were using Docker Compose up, I
wouldn't need to name that volume. But Right.
Okay.
So l s with modules,
dropout,
spin up, hope for the best. Don't be
wrong.
Okay.
So then I can run n p m
I. It should just be really fast.
Well, as fast as n p m I
can be. But
okay.
Next step was we wanna try
we'll try running dev without watch first, see
if it has a problem with that public
directory and whether we actually need to create
those
subdirectories or not.
But I'm assuming if they don't exist. I
mean, maybe not creating the public directory, but
I would hope that no one is happy
to create the subsequent directories.
What what other files were in there? Is
it just robots text?
So this persistence here tells me that this
is maybe a real file. I thought it
should exist. It is not ephemeral or generated.
Let's see.
Yeah.
P s good. Not very happy.
Is it big?
Let's
take a look.
Public CSS,
app CSS,
batch h,
1.2 meg,
74,000
lanes.
Let's just close the oh, I've actually closed
my whole course. Alright. Okay. It's been back
up.
Lost my directory now.
Okay.
Good.
Back into my initial.
So let's maybe stop in that fail and
then then Well, it's so big. It must
be compiled.
Right?
It's not compiled.
Wow. This is
oh, this is the tailwind fail.
No one's written that.
But it may just be pasted pasted
in
the whole tailwind for configuration,
which will then be parsed in post CSS
to be minimized
later.
So that's meant see, now now we're in
this really weird territory where public is not
an ephemeral directory and is
is
not yeah.
Damn.
So what are the options? We could
build it into the image.
Assuming none of that stuff's actually gonna get
edited.
Let's mount it in first. And then Yeah.
Sorry. What I was gonna say there is
let's mount it in,
run the the development steps, see where that
asset completion
I mean Yeah. It must be out here.
Right? That's why these JS files are numbered.
In fact, here's what we can do.
Locally, let's
do an MPM.
Must be, like, a cache clear. Right?
Mhmm. And you can see if they're in
git.
Are we git to ignore? Okay. Ignore. Yeah.
That's a good idea.
Up a bit.
Yeah. CSS is there.
So they're the ephemeral ones.
So where
is that app CSS been generated if it's
not by the MPM?
Did you run it did you run it
locally
in the past
on host
last time?
Something like that.
Yes?
The native is in
git ignore.
But it's not mentioned that to the container.
I'm
saying you may have just generated it on
host when you're messing around with the code
previously.
Yeah. Okay. But how did we do that
then?
How can we how can we generate that
again?
Delete it or rename it and see if
it comes back again when you run the
command.
Alright. So we wanna go local. We want
to delete public CSS, app CSS,
and then we want to run the npm
run dev.
And your hypothesis beam, we wanna know if
that's created set again.
Yeah.
Could it be created by install?
I don't know if NPM drops stuff out
of node modules.
It was generated right there.
So we can use the git ignore as
a list of things that we want to
have as volumes.
It's effectively a list of the ephemeral folders.
Right?
Yes.
So you're let me clarify what you're saying
there. Is you believe the problem that this
is failing is because it's missing access
something?
And if we tweak our
so so that would mean there's something on
the public directory that we're not mounting that
is needed.
Yeah.
But if we look at this direction Probably
something how unrelated.
I just don't see what it could be.
You could try running it with a
mount of everything. Just mount dot and then
just to debug, check that works,
and take things out rather than adding things
in.
Excuse me.
Okay. Let's try it.
But we're saying we want to mount everything
to node.
Mhmm.
Node modules go over the top. I'm hoping
that works.
It can be a bit weird trying to
work out the order that's gonna happen in
and then MPM or dev.
And assuming that the
yeah. It didn't look like there were any
specific files get ignored.
We could check that. It looks like they
have got distinction between,
you know, ephemeral folders and non ephemeral folders.
So we could use that list in the
gitignore
as a list of things that we need
to mount as volumes.
Okay. I think that's a
solid idea.
Alright. So that worked.
So we
still wanna be in a position where we
don't have this.
We want this. So what what consider missing
then? Split open, get ignore, see what's there.
Because if we probably we're having was we're
we think we're having was is mounting public.
I I don't think it's public. I think
we're missing something from the root now. Okay.
I I think.
Okay. So
we got tailwind. We got webpack.
We don't have we don't have package lock,
do we?
It can't be that. It
could be.
Maybe maybe we should rule it.
Maybe we should rule that. Oh, wait. Do
we need Bootstrap? No. We have the PHP
Bootstrap, so it's not like a JavaScript Bootstrap.
At
nope. It's all very PHP centric. Opt is
my stuff. Database is not important now.
We source these.
We mount all of that in any way.
Storage PHP
test.
I mean,
let's add the lock, and then I'm gonna
so let's roll it out. Right? Yep.
So no with that package
lock
JSON.
I want to stick it down next to
this one. Alright.
So we drop it at this. We spin
this back up.
Thought it was the name. Alright.
So now we have our package or package
lock.
Should I blow in node modules to rule
that out now that we're bringing in this
lock and bail?
It's in We can just we'll just trust
MPM to kinda fix that up just now.
And if this works,
then we're actually in a position where there
is maybe a break
by automatically pulling in the updates. But I
am gonna refuse to believe that is the
case.
So you look at all these vulnerabilities
and there's lock fail version.
Yeah.
Right. This is this is the stuff you
don't want.
Okay. Run
dev.
But, of course, you also want your application
to work for a while. So That reminds
me. I did work in an environment where
there was some sort of corporate
vetting of which packages were allowed in.
So Yeah. They
had to have the lock file
in case one of their vendors went rogue
and stuck in some malware.
Sort of tightly regulated
setup.
Same error.
And that fail actually does exist.
Scroll up to the error message. Did it
have a trail leading forward
slash?
Yeah. Let me just again.
Should've cat should've catered that fail.
That 1.4 meg text file with 74,000
lines in it.
Let's just drag this up to
So node resources CSS up CSS.
Right. Or let's let's actually read the message.
Ah. Slash
public.
Root fail system public CSS app CSS.
Not slash node slash public.
So that's our issue.
Why?
It's great. One one thing we're not better
than is dot e n v.
Don't see anything particularly useful here.
So we think that somewhere there's a config
that tells it what folder to use. But
it must be relative because it's a
it's a project that one of the files
that didn't mount
tells it, use the current folder for this
install.
Indeed.
So let's take a look.
Is that
let's try and understand this. There's not gonna
be specific path anywhere because
So this is the post CSS right here.
We should use a Laravel mix. We do
have a Laravel
mix. Do we have a Laravel mix config?
Yeah. This
makes manifest. No. That's, like, the payload asset.
Okay. Something
in here is telling it where to find
those files.
So
the work's fine in the PHP environment. That's
worth pointing out. Like, if I come up
here
I don't That's my
It worked fine when we mounted everything.
Yeah. When we mount everything, it's fine.
In a in a
when we mounted everything into an NPM container
that doesn't have PHP, so there isn't a
PHP file doing it.
Is there anything it could be looking at
that isn't
right. So when we when we run it
normally,
it would look at, like, the current working
directory, probably.
The p w d or the c.
That will all get sent to the
working folder.
Let's try app env
on a web.
Can you look at the
mixed configuration again?
Yeah.
Sure.
Yeah. Alright. Okay.
So
this is
So if I'm just looking at some of
the docs.
That dot j s method
is source and a destination.
And that post CSS
mess this right hand the second parameters are
destinations
Yep.
Which look relative.
They do, which is why I'm assuming something
in dot e n v is to use
the current working directory, which is I was
hoping with the app and local.
Mean Is the current working directory not the
It is.
If you echo c w d or whatever.
Yeah.
Oh, I have p w d. Sorry.
It's gonna be something
so
easy and simple
if you know
if you know.
There's a method set public path.
But
Let's
try.
Oops. But in tier
front failures now.
Package dot JSON. There's nothing environment specific here.
Do we have the CSS directory?
Is it created at the point we're running
the command? Yeah. We we do have an
app dot CSS fail in that directory where
we run the develop command. Yeah.
I'm gonna take a look at
so we can actually see the web pack
config. And if we take a look at
that, that should expose
any environment variables that are needed.
So We need somebody knows how to use
mix on the chat, don't we?
Yeah. I was hoping for a magical comment
from somebody, but not today.
Right. So we've got them now. Let's take
a look at this actual config.
Right away, Max is trying to load something
from source index,
but that's from
its source. So it should be fine.
I've got edit task,
webpack builder.
That
wasn't very useful.
It just must be something.
Don't wanna rest the stream just to be
us reading the mixed document.
It is what it is. We're so we
said we're gonna slow it down, and we
were gonna do this properly,
and that means trying to learn new APIs.
Yeah.
Right. So
okay.
So it's
determined a path to the user's webpack mix
dot j s. Looks for
webpack dot mix.
We need to make sure that's in the
right path.
The route is then set
to the route.
Okay. This looks interesting.
So either looks at
yeah. It looks at process dot c w
d.
Yeah. On one one path.
So how can we ensure it takes that
path?
Put in Right. Okay. We're loading it.
So we do have webpack dot mix here,
which
kinda tells me that that should be in
setup.
Config.
Alright. So node ENB.
Okay. That just says that I have a
flag test.
Public path is
blank
resource rich
slash.
Is
that what we're looking for?
Resource view. We have two comments.
Oh.
They're not applicable.
I mean, this I read.
Okay. So
I feel like this should work. I feel
like we're mounting enough.
I mean, I know we're not.
So what was so what was that resource
route comp setting
that you just looked up?
It was set forward slash. Yeah. So I
think this is a default configuration.
So if we come into source
config, there is a resource route.
I
guess if we do a quick grab
But maybe that's for external.
Then
we
see that as over we can overwrite it
via the API.
If we call set resource group.
So
alright. So we it has to be a
fail. It works when we change the amount
to be a dot.
Yeah.
That's the bet that's really bugging me. We're
we're good developers. Right? We can do a,
like, a some binary
search.
Can you
I'm good about this file. Let's mount ENV
first. It's a really nice my thing because
it just feels instinctively like that is the
file.
I mean,
I guess I don't need to mind that
we can use ENV file.
I don't know. Because we had that syntax
issue last time. Okay.
Dot ENV to slash node dot ENV.
Let's drop out
and see if that changes
how this code run.
And it does not. Okay. So let's mount
and let's just keep adding files.
We'll add half of them.
You want a binary search that fails in
the missing configuration?
Are we are we assuming it's a file
that's in the root?
So
just get the full list of all the
files, paste it into your VIM, do a
quick
VIM magic,
mount them all,
and we'll find out if it's one of
the ones that's in the root folder first
rather than something buried in one
of those other folders.
Sorry. Can you say that again?
Just get the list of all the files
and make a mount for all of them
in whatever the quickest way is.
Copy paste. Do some Vim
craziness.
Okay.
Not the ones that are folders.
So grip out the ones that start with
d.
Right. Hold on.
S dash l. Now what we only want
files. We don't want folders.
Grip dash v.
So we don't want anything that has
dash e e v.
D. D. How's it?
It's d at the start. We don't want
Yeah.
So we're doing a regex graph where the
lane starts with a d
and arc
prints
one, two, three, four, five, six,
nine.
There we go.
And then said?
Or you can do it in Rawk, actually,
can't you? Just print.
We could do a begin statement. So begin
No. You can just do a print line
space. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm over complicating
it now. So, yeah, we could do
dash
and copy it. Can we copy?
Some
shelters were Okay.
Wouldn't it be amazing if it turned out
to be the license?
I
don't think that's gonna happen.
Alistair Steve says I have a table and
a dot EMV night.
Oh, thanks, Alistair.
Is there ah, of course, it didn't.
I mean, we haven't confirmed that that is
the problem, but that's where my hunch is.
So let's comment this out. Yeah. Test that
test my hunch.
He always adds a bit of value as
well.
I can't believe you're not even catching my
tapers.
Quite a few of them.
Neither have I, not a dev.
Celebrating too early.
Okay.
My hutch did not work, so we're gonna
bring in everything.
We don't actually list the dot files,
but let's try anyway. We can always add
the dot files. Yeah.
No.
So it's something in the folder.
Either that or it could be one of
the dots. There's an ESLint.
Oh, I just lost access to my
You need to plug it in.
I do need to plug it in more.
Let's check this ESLint.
Yeah. I don't
think that would be needed to run our
dev step, but I will validate that.
K. Let's
let's run our wacky thing again.
This time at the LSE,
let's get all those fails
including the dots. Oh, that does work.
Delete.
Stick it back in.
It'd be good if any sort of junior
developers are watching to see this is what
you spend a lot of time doing.
Twenty years I've been doing this, and I
still spend all my time debugging.
In fact, I spend more time debugging those
than I ever did, probably.
And if this doesn't work, that means we're
looking at something which is in a nested
subdirectory
somewhere.
Really annoying.
Okay.
Alright. Let's try.
You know what? Let's
So
try all the folders?
Yeah. Try everything. So I'm just gonna remove
the Gorep here.
Well, no. Just invert it.
Because we want to
we know everything. If we mount everything that
it works.
Okay.
So true. See if it works, just take
the v out.
Oh.
Oh, yeah. Oh.
Well, that must still work, actually.
It would also catch any
files with d in.
Yeah.
Alright.
So we want
directory's
only. Okay.
Tripod thing is gonna get very annoying fast.
Okay.
Can't type.
Alright.
And then we'll just start ruling out the
things that we're pretty confident it is not.
Although, how funny would it be if this
fails?
I'll probably
go out and face something on the window.
Yeah.
It should work.
I mean, it might not work. This should
work.
It failed.
New hypothesis?
I'm working on it.
Did it work with a dot? Are we
making that Hang
on, David.
Don't know those files need to have where
are they gonna be mounted?
Those mounts.
Don't worry. I'm just creating a bunch of
dead volume.
Yeah.
So
we haven't actually been checking anything before.
No.
Okay. Let
Let's go back to the theory. It's one
of the files in the root
for now.
I make myself laugh sometimes. Other times, I
make myself cry.
But we'll feel really good when we figure
it out.
Okay.
I'm I'm sure there's a way to automate
this, but right now, it's not popping into
my head. You can automate it on the
command line again. So delete delete it all.
Yeah. I can do print print print. Yeah.
Okay.
Good idea. So we want dash dash dash
colon
slash
node slash
print name.
See, that's why you're here.
It's what good copilot does, isn't it? Shut
up when you're doing it.
Chip in with useful thing.
So it wasn't an error because Docker Compose
was creating lots of volumes.
Okay.
That's not quite right.
I didn't add on
flash.
It's just a
I can't remember how to do multiple cursors
on a Mac. On Linux, I've got it
down, but my the key is different. I
don't know Versus code.
Okay.
Alright. Hypothesis one, validation 14.
To put it that point is mounting everything
explicitly, is it?
Yeah. So we can probably just remove.
And then we'll do a half. We'll do
a Oh, that's the that's the directions we've
done.
So let's get the files now.
Did it work?
Well, no. Because I completed the righties. We
wanted to set the files first.
What's the error message?
That was a duplicate mode because of
stuff. So I'm just gonna take out all
of these midpoints
except for the node modules.
So we're gonna mount our node modules and
everything locally.
That is a fail.
Just for my sanity, can you check node
modules is in git ignore?
And there isn't some
super significant
It is. Yeah. Okay. That
would be crazy.
Okay. So now we are mounting every fail
in the root directory and so the container
very,
very manually. David David, look in the chat.
Has some has this person saved us? They're
anonymous.
No.
I would be very disappointed
if Moxie's
wrapper
around webpack required Artisan to exist, which means
you're probably right. Have a look at the
Artisan file. What's in it?
PHP?
But maybe it uses the artisan file
the presence of the artisan file for some
sort of
directory
relativeness to to find the root. Do you
know what I mean?
I didn't write it. Let's
Right. We know it doesn't have to run
PHP because we might end up, and it
worked. Right?
Yeah. But I'm saying I've seen projects that
find the root folder by finding where the
dot git folder is,
Things like that.
Okay. So we're gonna comment all of this.
We are gonna mount an artisan.
And we do need all the other stuff.
Yeah. The JS.
Let's try and go back to what we
actually wanted
though, right, which was to maintain resources.
We
we need public directory.
And then the web pack stuff.
Okay. It was just wait. It's okay. So
public, we've done resources.
Yep.
Okay. Let's try this.
And we're just about out of time as
well, which is unfortunate.
At least the show notes for this episode
will be really easy. Like, watch Kieran struggle.
What did Kieran and David struggle for forty
minutes? I can't believe that worked.
Yeah. Why why
does that need to
guess you can't use mix outside of Laravel
projects.
But you should try it try it with
an empty file called artisan.
Just for a laugh.
Oh, yeah. Because that's really that's so fun.
Alright.
Alright. So let's let's let's make it field
first again. Right?
And I'll touch touch artisan
and see if it passes.
And then someone could go and open a
very strongly worded issue against this repository.
Sorry. A politely worded issue. It's frustrating,
you know, this stuff happens.
Yeah. You gotta see it from the point
of view of someone who who's every every
project they ever have has an artisan file,
and it's a great way of locating.
Yeah.
Nice idea.
Is it?
An environment variable would have been just as
good.
I've written code that looks for composer JSON.
Let's just put it that way.
Unbelievable.
No. Thank you. No. If that was not
for your comment, we would have spent at
least the next three weeks.
So
do we have enough time to add to
the watch container that we were
trying to
Let's confirm that command work.
It should
no different from develop except the runs watching
the fail.
Alright.
So that means well, we can delete all
of that. I mean, I think that debugging
process is as painful as that may be
for some people to watch. There was some
good nuggets of bash there for people to
to learn.
Yeah.
No.
Okay. So we wanna automate that. So we're
gonna set our entry point to be MPM.
We'll set the command to be run or
watch. So that will now run that on
alert. Anytime those assets change, we'll see that
completion step happen.
We can now then
expose this public directory to engine x.
So instead of mounting in the local public,
we are going uphill or volume
from here.
Mhmm. That makes sense? Mhmm.
Okay. So let's
do
Did
Just spin it all up. We can just
Did you make did you actually make that
change? I think
Which Which Look at the YAML again?
Yeah. You have. Sorry. Yeah.
I can run a Docker Compose PS. We're
gonna see engine x is running. Hopefully, it's
not been running long. It has our new
changes. We've got our node watch running.
Now let's confirm this works.
We should be able to reload this.
And
dashboard two is there. Now the final test
is if I change that to dashboard three.
Can you tell the locks of the watch
container?
Yeah. Sure.
Note.
And we wanna change that view template from
earlier, which was here.
If I can find out this here.
It's time for dashboard three.
Compilation step.
Jump over here.
Oh.
Oh, no. Wait. It sent two places in
that file, actually.
That's for three.
There's that's oh, yeah. There's another one here.
That's the title tag, I think.
That should run.
Is this browser cache issue?
Do a force reload.
Alright. Let's let me let's confirm that what's
running.
Yeah. Definitely. Okay.
Let's check the NGINX container.
Is this NGINX?
No. I see PHP.
D c e x d NGINX
bash.
Email.
Public.
Nope. Where did we mount that to?
The w w w HTML.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh,
yeah. Oh, wait.
There's no view templates. Oh, okay.
We don't expect the view templates to be
there, do we?
No. We should change the CSS.
How would it be
I wish I knew how view worked. They'll
be in this
in the logs it was generating. In the
tailed logs,
it generated j s 13 dot j s.
So one line.
Yeah.
So, I mean, we could we should be
able to see this fail of the actual
dashboard for a floor. Right?
And we're hoping dashboard four,
three,
two. So two okay. So that's interesting.
Okay. Let's confirm.
JS was edited at 12:17.
I have a reservation, Dave.
No. You so the file you edited was
in resources.
Correct.
Yep.
And it's the same volume in both containers.
So is does it contain a two or
a three
when you look at that folder from the
node
running container?
Okay. So from a node point of view
Yes. If you shell into the node one.
Resources.
Where was Public.
It's node public.
Yes.
Cat 13.
Correct.
Dashboard
four.
Nope. That work two is still there.
Is this us just not understanding Vue?
I
mean, I definitely have never used Vue before
in my entire life.
So let's
but we do see asset compilation. We do
see JavaScript files being written. Let's change the
CSS. Let's let's maybe you're right. Right? Okay.
So what about if we change one of
these colors?
Mhmm.
That would be in the tailwind thing, though,
I think.
So it's basically, if you would change the
class name and the template. Well, let's change
indigo to be
black.
I'm assuming that indigo is the state bar.
Yes. I rock and roll.
And
that's now run again.
Okay. That worked.
So it's just us not knowing how to
edit the view thing.
Alright.
Let's
wrap this up and explain,
hopefully, what the hell we did. So
we have separate seats
very painfully,
node watcher
out of our PHP serving image into its
own container that runs in the background, continually
watching the assets, recompiling the JavaScript and the
CSS.
Now I think you're right that we don't
understand the view component of this yet, which
is why that dashboard change never made it
on the live reloading bit. But we were
able to change the tailwind configuration, and I'm
assuming we could change other parts of that
CSS and JavaScript to work.
So we do need to work at the
view component next time.
What
else? What have I meant?
That's what we did.
I got it.
I mean, we haven't modified the product we
didn't modify any of the production deploy stuff
because that already builds the
same pipeline
successfully.
Yeah. We just focused on trying to get
a shorter feedback loop in the development environment.
That means that on our next session or
we can definitely tackle the view template. We
can work out how we we trigger the
the rebuild, the redeploy, whatever has to happen
there. I don't even know if Laravel delivers
the view, and I'll need to do a
little bit of research on that. I'll spare
people that on the stream.
Then we will move back over to the
PHP development environment and really clean up that
workflow as well with regards to how we
interact with composer.
How do we run tests? And yeah. We
definitely will tackle the tests on the next
session for sure. Okay. Look forward to it.
Alright. Awesome. That was
challenging,
but really, I I I definitely learned a
lot from Yeah. Just working with the this
tool. Again, Laravel is new to both of
us, but I think we're making good progress.
And, hopefully, people find this useful. So, you
know, thank you for tuning in. Keenan, thank
you for joining me. It was an absolute
pleasure again. Enjoyed it. And I will see
you all soon. Thanks.